este 10 de septiembre es fiesta nacional
en belice se conmemora la batalla de san
george y un pasado colonial que podría
entrar en un proceso de descolonización
por cuenta de la creación de una
comisión que le quiere preguntar a los
beliceños si es momento o no de
desprenderse de la monarquía británica y
formarse como una república
anda siempre dices no estoy segura de
que los beliceños y estemos listos para
desligarnos del reino unido quizás en el
futuro cercano pero todavía pienso que
necesitamos estar bajo la corona
uniforme y no firmo hoy eres la reina
isabel visitó en dos ocasiones me dice
en 1985 y en 1994 la última visita a
este país de la familia real ocurrió en
marzo de este año con el príncipe
william y también su esposa kate
middleton quienes vinieron en momentos
en que países como belice y también
jamaica se cuestionan si deben seguir
bajo el manto de los británicos women
with the monarquía de momento conocemos
a la monarquía por el momento queremos
simpatizar con la familia real y
esperamos seguir caminando de la mano
con él carlos tercero en el top y one
with que lo podamos hacer por cuenta
propia hunter we can do it and aún
aunque hoy sea día de fiesta aquí en
belice celebrando la relación con el
reino unido el primer ministro jan y
briseño anunció que se le rendirá un
sentido homenaje a la memoria de la
reina isabel segundo a quien fungió como
la amalgama de los reinos de la
commonwealth una empresa que ahora queda
en manos del rey carlos tercero